I love Prezi. It's an awesome tool that let's me think high level, as well
as drill down into the details of each one of the steps we showed you.
>> And the next level of detail would be to go over to the actual UI
elements, within each of those flows. But unfortunately,
we're not going to cover that in this course.
>> Yeah, and that's where mobile constraints
come in, when we think about the implementation.
>> So let's talk about the mobile user constraints. You want to
think about handedness and decide whether or not your user experience is
one-handed or two-handed, and keep that in mind even though
we're not going to go into the UI elements right now.
>> Yeah. Another thing you want to keep in mind is limited data and battery life
and sketchy network. So when you think about
the menu and the order history and all that
information that has to be downloaded for this
application to work, think about synching that intelligently so
you're not draining battery, and so that it
works in non-fly mode. So for divided attention and
small screen, you have to make sure that the user
interface is built in such a way that it doesn't overwhelm
the user with too much information because again, they're, Debbie
is out and about doing things. Also make intelligent use of
notifications, and that's a great way to give Debbie information
when she needs it, relevant to your application. For example, in
the order status update and that way they don't have to
open your application and spend any more effort than they absolutely
need to to get what they need from your app.